touch let me know the screen looks good
to me
i will get back to you at 10 15 pacific
thank you
okay great thank you all right good
morning good
afternoon everybody um my name is
michael baltos from
orderflows.com and you know today i'll
be talking about order float strategies
for today's trading environment you know
it's uh
it's been a very interesting year you
know the market's been all over the
place you know even
um you know today we're down about what
up one and a half percent
and you know it was a very interesting
presentation by john
on the last presentation you know he has
a more macro view i have a more
short-term view intraday trading you
know there are
so many ways to approach the market
right there's no right or wrong way
to take money out of the market you know
like i said there's literally
probably thousands of different ways to
make money in the market and
your job as a trader is to go in and
take that money in
take that money out rather day in and
day out so if i have your permission you
know i'd love to share
what works for me and that's order flow
analysis so
you know for those of you that are new
to order flow and new to who i am
you know just a brief background of my
training experience so this is real-time
trading experience so i've
started on the cme floor as a runner
with dean ritter reynolds that was in
the early 1990s
eventually as i saw the exchange
offering
different forms of electronic trading
you know cme had globex cbot had project
and nymex had access
i realized you know that's probably
going to be the future of trading and i
left the floor to work on
the off the floor trading desk where i
would be trading electronically
for the firm and i spent a few years
trading electronically with dean witter
after that i joined another company edf
man the big english trading company i
spent two years there's global macro
trader
then i left to join commerce bank where
i spent three years as a ux trader
licensed urex trader
trading boons bobbles shots against the
us products you know the 10 years
um the five years uh and the s
ps then you know after september 11th i
needed a break
i you know i lost some friends in the
attacks and
you know i took about six months off and
basically just chilled out you know i
did some traveling
and eventually when i said yeah i got to
get you know i
i missed the markets i want to start
trading i joined this company called
cargill
for those of you that aren't familiar
with cargill it's one of the largest
companies
in the world it's a privately held
company but it's a big commodity trading
company
i joined their trading desk in chicago
and eventually they sent me out to
singapore
to set up a trading desk when the
exchange in singapore
decided to go electronic i spent four
years there
and after that i joined jp morgan i
was the vice president of futures
trading i spent eight years there
and i got to the point where i was just
really tired of the whole
getting in the morning going to the
office spending
more time in the office than in the
house and
you know after my daughter was born i
was like you know this is ridiculous my
daughter was just born but
i don't have any time for her so i left
i left jp morgan in
2013 and you know my thing was you know
i was 43 at the time i said you know
there's more to life than you know
working
in a corporate environment you know i
said i know how to trade i want to
just trade for myself so i started
writing a book on trading with order
flow which is what i used you know
throughout my trading career
and then as i was writing my book you
know i was still trading for myself
and the software that i was using to
analyze the order flow
you know i realized it could do so much
more
so i started this company called
orderflows.com which is my software
company
and i'll explain that a little bit more
later but you know the book that i wrote
is 150 page book if you stick around to
the end
i'm going to show you how you get a copy
of my book for free you know it's it's a
very interesting book you know a lot of
people tell me you know it's made a big
difference
in their trading and i'll give you um a
link where you go
and download the book for free
now i mentioned briefly about my
software company orderflows.com
and the reason i bring that up right now
is because
you know the charts that i'm be using in
this presentation are generated
from my software okay it's it's
you you got to trade with you know
something that is going to make your
life
easier and i created
the software for my own trading and it
wasn't until i started showing other
trader friends the software that i was
using which basically took the basic
order flow software to another level
you know it's it really opened a lot of
people's eyes and
you know it really transformed a lot of
traders from borderline you know
breaking even some days
you know up a couple hundred dollars
some days down a couple hundred dollars
to being consistent and that's what you
want to be as a trader
is you want to be consistent so
before i jump in just a brief disclaimer
do understand that trading involves risk
okay there's no guarantee in this world
you know
i i like to think the markets will keep
going up and up and up
but you know there's there's going to be
days that where the market pull back
right john on the previous one
yeah he just mentioned about dow 120 000
i hope to god that happens but you know
in the meantime
before we get to 120 000 it may come
back down to
uh you know 10 000 or 15 000. you got to
realize markets fluctuate
so today is september 17th right and
it really has been a long year we still
got another quarter left
and it's just been fascinating this this
year it's like
what else can happen in the world
and further step in the markets this
year
you know it's just it just seems so
chaotic honestly
you know as a trader you you really want
to make sense of what's happening in the
market you know just some headlines
you know global food markets braced for
uncertainty in 2021 because of covid
you know traders brace for haywire
markets around the presidential election
global stocks and oil prices drop as
investors brace for another week of
uncertainty you know if you
read the newspaper or watch news it's
it's all
basically just gloom and doom okay you
know donald trump the other day uh
two weeks ago sent out a tweet all right
hey dow jones just closed above 29 000.
great news yeah yippie yippie what
happens the market sells off the next
day
and sells off you know over the
subsequent days
you know yesterday right jerome powell
ah
but you know we're going to keep rates
steady okay you know that that's
should be good for the markets you know
markets did rally but as powell was
talking
the markets rallied up to new highs and
eventually sold off to new lows
and went lower and right now we're down
another one and a half percent you know
so
don't panic there's money to be made
during market uncertainty right but
keep in mind everyone always talks about
volatility
volatility can be your best friend and
it could also be
your worst enemy you know it's like
having a girlfriend or a boyfriend you
know
sometimes you love them sometimes they
hate them you know that's what
volatility is
and i want to share with you orderful
strategies that work in normal marketing
conditions as well as volatile market
conditions
now please remember right the market
does not trade in a bubble
right in the sense that you should look
beyond what the bar right in front of
you is doing
and understand what the market is doing
in general you
got to be asking yourself is the market
trending up or is it trending down or
going sideways
now order flow shows where
and how much traders are committed to
the market and that's important
right because when someone's in a
position
they are committed to that position
you know they're either going to be
making money which is good or they're
going to be losing money which is bad
and at some point they're going to have
to get out
and that's all going to show up in the
order flow now
you know in the old days you know when
people talked about order flow you know
it was a little ticker tape machines
you know with with the you know the the
prices coming by in the stock name
saying oh you know
at t traded um 5 000 contracts at
5 000 shares at you know 21 and 3 8.
now you know there's a time and sales
everything is traded electronically
but to be honest you know time and sales
moves very fast
and with the proliferation of
algorithmic trading you know a lot of it
happens on very small
lot size and you know it could be
happening on one contract one contract
one contract
you can't keep track of it now what a
lot of traders like to look at
is the depth of market which is the
order book right where you can see
what the passive buyers or the passive
sellers are doing
you know how much they're working at a
certain price
and you could also see you know when
aggressive buyers or aggressive sellers
are active in the market
you know but to be honest
looking at the time and sales or looking
at the dome
is very confusing right you need
a way to organize it so that you can use
it right and
we all like to think that we're the
smartest person in the room
in the sense that you know we could make
sense of everything
but to be honest when things are
happening so fast in the market
it's very difficult right see you need a
way to take all that information from
the dome
from the time and sales and utilize it
okay so a volume footprint chart an
order flow volume footprint chart takes
all that information
right that's scrolling through the dome
that's moving so fast
you know in a second hundreds of
contracts trading or
what you're seeing um you know on the
bid and offer you see
trades going back and forth okay i said
unless you're
brainiac you know you're not gonna be
able to make heads or tails of it
so why not take that data and put it
into an easy to read format right which
is the footprint chart
so take all the trade data from the time
and sales the information of executed
trades
on the dome and put it in a chart format
which we're all familiar with
so that we can analyze how much was
bought on the offer how much was sold
into the bid
and you'll make make educated trading
decisions based on that
the footprint chart is going to allow
you to see where buyers or sellers are
stronger or weaker
you know when buyers appear after the
market's been selling off
or when sellers appear after a rally
right that's very important information
you're going to see where the value is
right now where the market is trading
you're gonna see when the market is
getting exhausted you know and when
people talk about if you're not familiar
with the term
market exhaustion in terms of um
trading you know what it market
exhaustion is is
you know think of this right market's
been selling off okay
where is it going to stop right it's
going to stop eventually and it's often
going to stop when
the last seller has sold just as a rally
will stop
when the last buyer has bought right if
there's no more buyers in a move up
then the buyers are exhausted right what
do you expect the market to do go higher
no of course not it's probably gonna
stop right there turn around and sell
off
but the order flow chart allows you to
see all that and much more
so what makes order flow so useful is
you can use it with your existing chart
right you could use it with time based
charts you could use it with range based
charts
use it with tick based charts so if you
use a one minute chart you could use
order flow if you use a
eight range chart you could use order
flow if you use you know
a thousand tick chart or a thousand
volume chart you can use
with order flow if you're trying to read
the order flow from the depth of market
the price ladder or time and sales
you really got to concentrate and you're
just sort of limited
to that that chart that
minutia in what's happening in the
market so
you know this is yesterday yeah all the
charts i'm going to be showing you
just happened yesterday yesterday was a
very fascinating day
in market activity so with order flow
there's three main things you've got to
keep in mind
and what they are is the delta the
imbalances and the point of control now
the delta
is going to be the net difference
between the aggressive buyers and
sellers in the market
you know in the old days um you know
when the market would go up you'd call
your broker
and you'd ask well why's the market
going up you say well there's more
buyers and sellers no
it's going up because you have more
aggressive buyers than
passive sellers they're buying all the
offers on the way up and moving it
higher they're looking for the next
higher price
and why that's important is because
that's a piece of information you're
going to get from the order flow
it's called the delta right so if you
see
a bar that has positive delta
right what that means is aggressive
sellers were
in control of the bar and the delta
on most order flow charts let me get my
pointer here
okay it will appear along the bottom of
the chart so you can see
each bar has a delta it's either going
to be a positive number or a negative
number
so when you're up trading near the high
of the day as we were yesterday
around 1 42
you notice the delta right it's negative
it's getting stronger negative
that's not a good sign of a market ready
to go higher
right we had just shot up if you
remember then all of a sudden
delta is getting negative and it's
getting stronger minus 83 minus 405
minus 450 so you know over these three
this group of three bars there's some
strong selling going on in here
okay so if you're thinking well maybe
this is a nice pullback i can be looking
to get long
no right you should be thinking the
opposite because you're seeing well
there's some very strong selling going
on
now imbalances is when you have more
aggressive buyers
than sellers or vice versa in the
two-way auction between the bid and the
offer
and it will appear in the order flow as
a red number
or for a selling and balance or a blue
number for buying and balance
okay and again you know that's important
because
in a bar right some bars have
evenly matched order flow right where
traders are happy to transact
it's not necessarily out of balance
right because the on the market exists
to facilitate trade
but when you start seeing markets going
out of balance
when you start seeing bars with many
selling imbalances
chances are the market's going to go
lower
or just if you have multiple buying
balances
in that bar in the two-way auction it's
telling you you know
what's going on between the bid and the
offer prices the market tends to go
higher
okay that's why you see oftentimes in
markets moving up you're seeing buying
imbalances
in markets moving down you're gonna see
selling the balances now the point of
control
is the price level in a bar with the
most volume
now every bar has a point of control and
think of it as the value where the value
is in a bar okay and remember
markets move higher looking for new
value areas markets move lower looking
for new value
areas so you know keep those the three
things
in mind when you're analyzing the market
so a question i got a lot right which is
really what i want to talk about on this
presentation is
um you know over the last six months
with kovid
um with everything going on in politics
is how to trade order flow when the
market's very volatile
well the answer is simple you trade it
the same way right
a big mistake that i saw a lot of people
running into
back in in march and april this year um
basically blowing up you know or not say
blowing up but taking big losses
on their accounts is volatility
skyrocketed if you remember vix
um you know doubled you know in a few
weeks went up to like what 70s or
something which is off the charts you
know it's off the richter scale so high
is the way they handle it was they widen
their stops
and when you widen your stops you take
on a lot more risk
right i mean who wants to do that i know
i don't want to do that
i mean you know the whole point of
trading to be successful and consistent
is to
limit your risk as soon as you start
widening out your risks
you know when you take a loss it's
bigger right
another mistake they started doing was
well i gotta fine-tune my
indicators to you know take into account
all this extra volatility so
you know instead of looking at whatever
you know a 21-day move
and 21 period moving average also
they're looking at
you know 35 period moving average so
they're trying to
mathematically smooth out the volatility
of the market
you know and again you know they're
still that
they're still running into problems
right is this
you know the i've worked with a lot of
retail traders over the last several
years
um since leaving the institutional side
and
you know one of the big problems that
retail traders face and the reason why
they're not so consistent
is they keep changing things
right what you got to do is you got to
find something that works
you stick with it you know good times
and bad times you know i've seen people
take three bad trades and immediately
say oh you know what this doesn't work
well you know if you traded long enough
you know you're gonna have periods
you're gonna have days where
it just seems you can't do anything
right you know every trade that you take
just doesn't seem to work out you know
the
that's how the market is right we all
want to have days where you know we got
winners um but those days are rare right
i
i know guys that are you know some days
they show me their their
trading journal the trading log you know
they've got
you know they end up you know the day a
winner but you know they only had 20
winners on the day you know it's it's
not about trying to
after the fact curve fit your indicator
or widen your stop
so you could scoop up maybe some more
winners but your losses are so big
that's not what that's not how you trade
in volatile times right
why take on more risk than necessary or
trade
the way that you trade under
regular conditions so orderful is about
understanding the aggressive
what the aggressive traders are doing in
the market right and you can see it on a
dome
but watching the dome the depth of
market the price ladder is going to give
you a headache
right because the dome is nice it's a
useful tool
i look at it but i use it to help manage
trades
but you know trying to make trading
decisions off of it especially
with volatile market it's moving so fast
up and down especially
markets like nasdaq you can't make heads
or tails of it
right but if you have a nice way to
organize it which the volume footprint
chart is
you're going to be able to see what's
going on now this was the low yesterday
the the the new low around 2 230 we made
a low eventually
later on in the day but at this low by
reading
the order flow you could see there was
market exhaustion
you can see there was divergence right
you're at a low and also you've seen
buyers come in that's what the
divergence is in the order flow so
you're seeing
aggressive buying coming in at the low
of the day
right which is bullish you're also
seeing aggressive buyers step into the
market you're seeing
multiple buying imbalances coming in and
you're starting to see value start to
move
up when this whole time on the way down
it's been moving down
right now on a bar chart right this is
the low here you you're just guessing
blindly basically
you can't see was this smart is this
move exhausted
right is there divergence is there
aggressive buyers
are there buying imbalances what's value
doing you can't make those decisions
off a normal bar chart so
again market exhaustion right when the
last seller has sold in a move down
or when the last buyer has bought in a
move up
and here at the low of the day right we
have
a sign of market exhaustion right you
can see it in the volume
right there one contract traded at uh 75
and a half
in this bar right the previous bar
traded 17 on the bid
this next bar traded one okay so do you
think this market is going to go any
lower
all right the bars turned around closed
higher right
when we're trading right around the low
you finally get the last seller clicks
sell uh you know we've all sold the low
of the day we all hate it
but you know the market's moving down
you know people are full mowing you know
i gotta get short i gotta get short
finally the last guy gets to his
computer jumps hits the sell button boom
you made print right there at the low
market reversed up
okay market exhaustion this is very
simple concept in order flow
now divergence occurs when buyers net
buyers appear at the end of a move down
or net sellers appear at the end of the
move up
and we have it here as well right we got
our low of the day
we have positive delta right so again
delta is the net difference between
people buying the offer versus people
selling the bid
right those are the aggressive traders
so we're at the low of the day
and for a market to go lower right as
you see we're taking out the lows of the
day we're doing it on
negative delta minus 500 minus 1500
minus 360. but we hit that low again
but now the buyers have stepped out of
the woodwork yeah this is a great time
to buy
right and they get long they start
getting long in here 76 77
78 right this is a divergence in
order flow now aggressive participants
right there's two types there's
aggressive buyers there's aggressive
sellers aggressive buyers trade
immediately by buying
the offer price right they trade at the
market aggressive sellers is sellers
that do the opposite they trade
immediately by selling
the bid price right they trade at the
market though that's the important thing
is they want to get in
or get out of a position so they're
going to trade at the market price
they're not going to be working a bid or
an offer in the order book no aggressive
buyers
come in and they start buying
whatever's offered right and that's
going to show up in the delta right if
you have positive delta
you have aggressive buyers if you have
negative delta you have aggressive
sellers
right so what happened at this low of
the day here
positive delta right also you have the
divergence
even in the next bar also positive delta
so we're starting to move away from our
low
and aggressive buyers still stepping in
and we
rally up right we rally up over 10
points and we get up here
what do we see aggressive sellers coming
in now we're seeing a negative delta
right we're seeing negative delta after
a move up so
two things are going to be happening one
either the move is going to stop
or two it's going to go sideways
or three the aggressive sellers are
going to take over the market and the
market's going to continue down
in this case the aggressive sellers came
in here in this third bar outside the
box
slammed it right it was basically a
five-point sell-off
in 30 seconds it's a 30-second chart and
then the market actually you know
started going lower again
and eventually we took out the lows of
the day
made new lows so we see aggressive
buyers coming in at the lows
rally up aggressive sellers come in take
control
back from the aggressive buyers and move
the market back down
now imbalances are the result of
aggressive traders right so when
a buying a balance occurs is when the
aggressive buyers outnumber the
aggressive sellers in the two-way
auction by at least four to one
selling and balance is the opposite when
um aggressive sellers outnumber the
aggressive buyers
in the two-way auction by at least four
to one
so remember right the market is it's a
two-way auction there's a bid and
there's an offer
okay it doesn't trade at a single price
you know like it doesn't trade six and
seven it's
five bit at six six bit at seven et
cetera so
you can see there's as the market is
moving up you're seeing buying
imbalances
as the market starts hits that level
pauses
starts coming down you're seeing selling
imbalances just on this
move this dramatic move down you're
seeing mostly selling imbalances in here
okay now value
in a bar is regarded as the price level
where the most volume traded in that bar
and the value level in a bar is the poc
it's the point of control
it's the price level where the most
volume traded
on the bid and offer side okay so
every bar has a point of control every
bar has a
price level where it traded the most
volume okay
then you can see in each bar there's
like a gray box around it
right so as we're moving up from this
low right on the move down
you see lower points of controls markets
putting in lower value areas
we hit our low market starts ticking up
moving up
higher point of control on the second
bar higher point of control on the third
bar
higher point of control it gets up here
we got a point of control around the
88 and three quarters next bar lower
lower
lower lower as the market continued on
down
now all this information is there on the
time and sales
and the depth of market but it's so
confusing
right it's all happening so fast in a
volatile market
forget about trying to look at time and
sales you can't you can't keep up with
it period
dome okay it's an acquired skill okay
but you're really focusing in on certain
things right when you're looking
at a footprint chart you you're seeing a
lot more information
than just staring at well you know 78 on
the bid 98 on the offer
you know it's going to give you a better
view of the market
and at that low of the day yesterday
the initial low at around 233
we're seeing a lot of things in the
order flow that's very bullish you're
seeing market exhaustion
you're seeing divergence you're seeing
aggressive buyers
you're seeing value moving higher you're
seeing multiple buying imbalances
you know it's it's like the planets are
aligned right so to speak
um you know it's like you you got a lot
of
good evidence that yeah this is probably
the low for now
okay yeah i could safely be buying it
somewhere
you know off this low you know around
the 79
the 80 even 81 area right for a nice
move up into
a nice quick move again this is a 30
second chart you know you're talking
two three minutes you know six seven
points out of the market
in the e-minis
now on a bar chart you can't see what's
happening in the order flow right you're
not going to see that exhaustion you're
not going to see the divergence you're
not going to see the aggressive buyers
you're not going to see the buying and
balances you're not going to see what
value is doing
so order flow is not about
trying to predict a high or low right
it's not oh you know i'm going to
predict this low here
no it's about reacting to what's
happening in the market right
order flow is not an indicator it's the
market
right the market tells you what is
happening you know it's up to you
to listen to what the market is telling
you right it's
this is an e-mini one-minute chart okay
so this was the high of the day earlier
right we
we probably about uh 40 minutes earlier
we had just hit a high okay after the
fed announcement we rallied up
and at the high of the day what are we
seeing
okay well we're seeing a divergence
right
we get up to the high of the day all of
a sudden we're seeing negative delta
coming in here and getting stronger
minus
83 which is you know not the strongest
number but minus 400 minus 450 minus 566
minus 1050 okay we're making this
methodical move down and in the order
flow we're seeing
a lot of negative information right
we're seeing
aggressive sellers taking control of the
market in the delta
right we're seeing the value which is
the point of controls
migrating lower right they're moving
down on each bar
it's not you know just sort of hanging
around going sideways no it's
lower lower lower lower lower
now the other important thing to note
you know
the thing with you know when you talk
about value
in a bar okay most people don't talk
about the value in a bar because
well it's so short okay but do you ever
wonder why
the market pulls back exactly to a
specific
level in the bar well that's the value
area generally
right you can see on this move down okay
we have this red bar up here at the top
you see the point of control coming in
here was at 34 18.
the next bar trades right up to that
level that's the high of this bar
market moves down we put in a new lower
point of control
up here at 17 and a quarter the next bar
we trade one tick past it
okay and put in a lower point of control
it's coming in here at 16
34 16. next bar we trade right to that
point of control
and sell off just as on moves up
right we got the point of control here
at 12. you see this green bar
that's the low of this bar right you got
this red bar here point of control
it comes within one tick of it all right
this next bar
we trade up to this point of control one
tick past it next bar
this red bar sells off it comes right
back
to that value area here before closing
back in the middle
so you know it's it's fascinating how
why bars pull back to certain areas but
you can see it
in the order flow why it pulled back to
that area is because that's where value
was in the previous bar
i mean imagine you know being a trader
you know a beginning trader and
someone's telling you yeah i got a good
idea of where
the market could pull back to in the
next bar based on
what is happening in this bar you know
that's very useful
and good information that you can use in
your trading analysis
now what else are we seeing up here off
this high
right we're seeing selling imbalances
coming in okay
well these red numbers in here right
selling imbalances
yeah we got a few binding balances okay
it's not the end of the world um
you know you you do have some aggressive
counter trade but mostly
you got aggressive selling coming in so
again you know at this high of the day
we're seeing a lot of negative order
flow so at the low we were seeing
positive
order flow at the high we're seeing a
lot of negative overflow i'm not trying
to predict oh we just hit this new high
i think this is going to be the high no
i'm letting the market tell me that this
is potentially the high of the day
based on what's going on in the market
now just another quick market the euro
currency
okay again this was yesterday we had
this nice steady methodical move down as
well
down into new lows new lows new lows you
know from the 65
area where we're just trading sideways
but
you're looking at the exact same things
right you're seeing
the point of controls moving down right
you can see how
on this move down we literally just pull
back within a tick or two of the
previous point of control
okay you're seeing negative deltas in
here right so you know aggressive
sellers are in control
you're seeing very little aggressive
buying
um i don't want to talk about much this
today but i go over this
in other presentations is understanding
the max admin delta you see very little
aggressive buying in these bars with the
aggressive selling going on you can see
that in the max admin delta
you're seeing selling imbalances right
two here
two here four in this bar one in this
bar one in this bar
um five in this bar right but you know
really these three bars right here
should be
the sign to you that this market is
probably going to be making new lows
you're seeing market exhaustion
in this bar in this bar the small
volume being traded at the edges of the
bar
now earlier i said in volatile markets
you trade order flow
the same way why because you're
reacting to what's happening in the
market right
you're reacting to what the market is
telling you and showing you areas
you can enter the market with
potentially lower risk so
you'll be reacting to what the market is
giving you now
i will go through a bunch of different
charts here really quick
and again this was at the high of the
day okay so you know i just mentioned
in volatile markets you trade the order
flow the same way
okay so this is the e-mini one-minute
chart this is at the high of the day
okay and you're seeing value moving
lower
aggressive sellers in control very
little aggressive buyers against that
you're seeing divergence at the high
you're seeing selling a balance you're
seeing resistance selling
right on a five minute chart you're
seeing the exact same thing
on a volume based chart this is a 2500
volume based chart
again you're still seeing looking at the
exact same
thing in this case you don't have the
divergence but you got everything else
you got the selling and balances you got
the
net aggressive sellers you got point of
control moving lower you know everything
is still
the same so the 1000 tick chart
same thing right and you even have what
we call a prominent point of control
this red point of control up here which
is very important
in order for analysis it's telling you
there's
someone up here defending this position
it's resistance in the market and it's
based on what's happening in the order
flow
you got your divergence got your lower
point of controls
you've got your sound imbalances in here
you've got your
negative delta right so you know
it's there's there's so many different
chart types you know so many people
everybody almost looks at you know a
different chart type whether it's minute
based range based
tick based volume based but i'm showing
you you know it doesn't matter
right you can use your chart if you and
add order flow to it
and you can find yourself making better
trading decisions this is an eight range
chart
again all the same information on the
minute base chart the tick base chart
you're looking at the same data points
it's all giving you the same information
so i just showed you five different
charts and it's not because
i want you to have five different charts
open and at once and make sure
everything matches up
no that's not the point you know the
point i'm showing you these
different chart types is because you're
looking at the same things
looking for the same things rather no
matter what chart
or what market you're looking at right
whether you're looking at a one-minute
crude oil chart
or a one-minute micro e-mini chart
you're looking at for the same
information adding overflow analysis is
the difference between success and
failure for
many traders okay and order flow
generates a lot of useful information
for a trader
that you just don't get by looking at a
normal candlestick chart
so you know why not use that information
to your advantage
and the great thing is you don't have to
throw away your existing
method of trading right i'm just saying
why not
add another tool to help you make
more informed trading decisions
order flow is trading in its purest
sense it's reading the market
it's reacting to what's happening in the
market
and being able to make a great trading
decision
excuse me so hopefully by now you know
you should be ready to add
order flow analysis to your trading you
know even if it just helped you
keep out of a few bad trades a day you
know at the end of the month
you know that could be the difference
between having a successful month
and a losing month now there's different
ways you go about learning order flow
right you can try and learn it on your
own
right you could spend years looking at a
screen trying to figure it out
more importantly you could waste a lot
of money trading
thinking you know what you're looking at
but you don't really
and you lose that money you know give it
to the market and it's gone
you know that that's that's to me the
the biggest mistake a lot of people
don't realize is well i'll just try and
figure it out on my own
and you know they just waste their money
or number two you can get the education
and software from a trader who has
successfully traded
order flow at the highest level for
decades you know that's why i talked
about my background earlier
so you know where i applied order flow
that was my career i was trading
you know for jp morgan was trading for
cargill i was training for dean winter
that's how i made my living and you know
you don't last that long
at these firms unless you're making
money
right they don't keep you on you know a
training program for
two years you know if you're not making
money for the bank
you know in a in a quarter you know like
what's your problem
um you know so you're going to skip the
massive trading losses
because you're going to get the
education and you're going to skip the
wasted time
searching on google trying to figure out
watching videos so you know is this what
i'm supposed to look for no i'm going to
tell you what you're supposed to look
for
you know order flow is the most current
information available to a trader
it's not some indicator it's just the
market order flow is not based on pivot
levels it's not fibonacci it's not based
on elliott wave it's not based on macd
it's not based on v web order flows
what's trading on the bid what's trading
on the offer order flow
is the market so the order flows trader
software
it runs on ninjatrader eight you know
that's the platform that
i prefer to use you know it's it works
great i haven't had any issues with it
in
years and it's got a volume footprint
chart
with seven pre-programmed order flow
indicators already
in there okay and you also
get my chart template and also teach you
order flow trade setups normally i sell
the software for 8.99
on our website now i'll give you guys a
quick preview later this month we're
doing
a upgrade on the software order flows
trader 2.0 is going to become order
close trader 3.0
and you know we're still working on it
i'm in the beta
testing of the new software now but it
should be ready before the end of the
month
and you know if you get the software now
you're going to get the free upgrade
to it and if you have already have the
software you're also going to be
upgraded for free
i don't like to charge people for
upgrades you know you buy the software
you get the upgrades for free but having
order flow software is one thing right
the next thing
is knowing how to use it again you don't
just buy the software and oh that's it
go on your own figure it out
i also give you a lot of education on
how to trade with order flow
and each week i do a private live group
training just for users
if you can't attend you can watch the
recordings but if you can attend you can
ask me questions
and you know people email me questions
during the week and i try to answer them
as well
in the session you know there's over 80
sessions already i think 86 or something
that we've done over the last two years
and some people charge
200 a month for extra training why
you know you buy a software you want
training on it right
so why pay extra for training i give it
to you for free
but i also give you access to my order
flow trading course which is a course on
trading with order flow those 20 lessons
so 15 hours of video instructions it's a
great course for people that are new to
trading with order flow now for people
that are already
into order flow and they want advanced
trading information
i also give access to my inner circle
video series right it's this
collection of 56 videos on advanced
order flows tricks tips and
analysis so you know the software is
normally 8.99
the order flows trading course 297 the
inner circle video series
497. that's already 1693
plus you're going to get weekly live
group training where you could ask your
questions
tell me oh you know i don't understand
this thing about the order flow can you
explain it and i explain it
there for everybody that's in attendance
so think of it as this way it's like
skipping the line at disneyland
right it's like having mickey mouse come
on say hey come over here i got secret
entrance for you
you know where you know you're really
brought up to speed
but i got a special bonus for you guys
um
that come to my presentations through
investors expos
i have a course called the order flow
playbook
normally it's 297. and we give you that
for free
as well and it's a great course it's
kind of an advanced course on order flow
and there's a bunch of trade setups in
there
as well so you know when you add the
overflows playbook into that it's almost
two thousand dollars that you're paying
for that
but you know you're not going to be
paying that but you know what other
people are saying
is you know they're saying mike
you know here you know sheila writes you
know your order for software is
remarkably helpful i can clearly see now
what's happening in the market
like for example who's in control of the
market on a very specific time
and who's getting weaker as well you
know ziad writes you know i'm very
thankful for all the learning and yes my
trading and understanding financial
markets are
way much better than a lot of other
traders out there
okay so if you're worried you don't
know how to make heads or tails of
overflow i also include two guides my
top three trade setups
and hidden trading opportunities that
will help you understand what you're
seeing in the market
so you know to become successful
it takes work right you got to think
about what you got to do then you got
plan it
and you reached success so for a
one-time payment of just 675
you're going to get my software okay so
go to orderflows.com off to two
all right it takes you to the page all
right it's just a one-time payment now
you have to pay you know your data fees
of course no way of getting out of data
but um
you know those those are minimal if
you're a trader right it's cost of doing
business so
it'll take you to this page just scroll
down to click this button i want
now and it'll just take you to paypal
it's paid through paypal i don't get
your credit card i don't want your
credit card
and after that you know it'll take you
i'll send you out all the information
takes takes uh i
it takes a little bit of time to process
it but you'll get all the software and
all the training and all the guides
emailed to you to your paypal email
address now if you want my book
go to this page orderflows.combook.html
you'll have to enter your name and email
address make sure you put the book.html
on the web address it's not
orderflows.combook
it's overflows.combook.html
after you enter your name and email
you'll be taken to a
download page where you can download the
book instantly
so you know the best piece of advice i
give to you right now is
get started right it's a small payment
and
of just 6.75 it's a one-time payment
you know and we're doing an upgrade of
the software
should be out by the end of this month
and you'll be able to get that
upgrade which is a big upgrade right i
don't do upgrades
all the time we do about every two years
and we've got five
five new indicators included in the
software as well so
after this month and when we release the
new software actually the price is going
to be increasing so
this is your time to get the software at
the
lower price and take advantage of the
upgrade when it comes out
so thank you thank you anna um i don't
have time for questions but you know if
anyone's got a question just email me
mike
orderflows.com and i'll do my best to
get back to you
relatively soon so thanks anna and i'll
throw it back to you
thank you so much michael